At Macca's, we believe some things are bigger than all of us,...
...like feeding imaginations through 28 million books in Happy Meals.
Introducing fiber-based straws and cutlery.
Together, we'll save over 860 tons of plastic every year.
Setting young Aussies up for future success.
We're a family of over 106,000 and we're proud of each one.
Helping keep families together.
With your help, we've raised much-needed funds for Ronald McDonald House Charities...
...and things like supporting Aussie farmers,...
...sourcing 100% Australian beef and RSPCA-approved chicken...
...because we all need to do our bit to make a difference.
And for us, this is just the beginning.